(bird caws)
- [Instructor] What's that? That sound?
That call sounds like
something a crow would make,
but not quite.
That's actually the call of
a really interesting bird
called Clark's nutcracker.
These birds are cousins
of the American crow,
which you might see and
hear around where you live,
except that the Clark's
nutcrackers like to live
up in the mountains in alpine ecosystems
in the Western United States,
where the winters are pretty
harsh with lots of snow
and there are lots of evergreen
trees, like pine trees,
which keep their leaves
all throughout the year.
But what would this bird possibly eat
in this kind of ecosystem?
I'll give you a hint.
It's in the bird's name.
Turns out that Clark's
nutcrackers love eating seeds,
and not just any seeds,
but mainly the seeds of
pine trees, like this one,
the whitebark pine.
And it's actually good for the trees
that nutcrackers eat those seeds.
Wait. What?
Let's take a look at the whitebark pine.
These trees have cones,
which hold their seeds.
Other pine-tree species
have cones that will open
when the temperature is warm enough
or if the air is especially dry
or when the cone is exposed to fire,
but for the whitebark pine,
their cones don't open on their own.
Instead, the cones have to be pried open,
and the Clark's nutcracker that does this
as it looks for seeds to eat.
But the nutcracker doesn't
just eat the seeds.
It stores them in what's called
a cache, or a safe place,
where they store the
seeds to eat them later.
Remember, these birds live
in an alpine ecosystem,
where the spring and
summer are pretty warm
and there's lots to eat,
but the winters are cold and
long with very little to eat.
So the nutcrackers have to stock up.
In fact, the nutcrackers will
cache up to 100,000 seeds
in a single year.
I can't remember where I
put my phone half the time.
But the nutcrackers don't
retrieve all of these seeds.
Many of the caches won't
be used by the nutcrackers,
so those seed germinate and
grow into new whitebark pines,
and the cycle continues.
Nutcrackers rely on whitebark pines
as an important food source,
and the whitebark pines
rely on nutcrackers
to plant their seeds.
And on top of that, more
than 100 other alpine species
of plants and animals benefit
from that relationship
between the Clark's nutcracker
and the whitebark pine.
For example, Douglas
squirrels will also eat seeds
from whitebark pine cones
and mountain bluebirds
and northern flickers may nest
in the whitebark pine, too.
When you look at it, all
of these interactions
that occur in this all pine
ecosystem are like a web.
Each population interacts
with many other populations,
and each population is affected
by non-living parts of the environment
like temperature and snowfall.
So a change in any one
part of an ecosystem
can lead to changes in many of
the ecosystem's populations.
For example, if something
happens to the nutcrackers
and their population starts to decline,
that could cause some big
problems for the pines
that need these birds
to plant their seeds.
In turn, if the whitebark
pine starts to decline, too,
that can have negative impacts
on all the other species
that rely on this tree,
like squirrels, bluebirds, and flickers.
Even though it seems like
a perfect relationship
between the nutcracker and the
pine in the alpine ecosystem,
every ecosystem is dynamic,
meaning that parts of the ecosystem,
both living and non-living,
can and probably will change over time.
Sometimes, ecosystems might
experience a negative change,
like a disruption.
Maybe it's a particularly
harsh and cold spring,
and there aren't as many cones and seeds
for the nutcrackers to cache.
Changes like that can make it harder
for individual nutcrackers
to survive and raise chicks,
which can cause nutcracker
populations to get smaller.
But on the other hand,
other types of changes
can help individuals in a population.
For example,
if the ecosystem experienced
a particularly warm spring
after a wet winter, there would
be lots of available food.
These types of changes
can cause more individuals
to survive, have offspring,
and increase their population.
Clark's nutcrackers and their relationship
to the hard-to-open cones
of the whitebark pine
are just one example of
the kind of relationships
that drive many different ecosystems.
Just like how a decrease
in nutcracker populations
could cause problems
for the whitebark pine
and other species in the ecosystem,
a change to one species in any ecosystem
can impact a whole web of
interconnected organisms.
So next time you're outside
and hear the call of a bird,
think about all of the
interactions that bird has
with other parts of its ecosystem.
These relationships are all
part of the complicated web
that is life on Earth.
(bird caws)